>> Jesse: WE ALL LOVE TO MEASURE
OUR ACCOMPLISHMENTS, WHETHER
THEY ARE PERSONAL, PROFESSIONAL
OR EVEN ATHLETIC, YOU LIKE TO
TAKE STOCK OF WHERE YOU STAND.
AND IF YOU ARE TRULY THE BEST AT
SOMETHING, YOU MIGHT JUST SET A
RECORD.
MOST OF US WE LOVE WHEN A GOOD
RECORD IS BROKEN.
YOU KNOW THAT CAN TRIGGER A
HEATED DEBATE LIKE WHO REALLY IS
BASEBALL'S ALL-TIME HOME RUN
KING?
HELL, THERE IS EVEN ENTIRE BOOK
DEDICATED TO KEEPING TRACK OF
OUR MOST INSANE ACHIEVEMENTS.
BUT, UNFORTUNATELY FOR US, OUR
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF KEEPS
BREAKING RECORDS.
JUST NOT THE ONES WE WANT.
AFTER SETTING A NEW HIGH WITH
THE NUMBER OF ILLEGAL ALIENS
CROSSING THE BORDER, BIDEN HAS
DONE HIMSELF ONE BETTER.
WITH THE PRICE OF GAS
SKYROCKETING TO IT HIGHEST LEVEL
EVER.
A GALLON OF GAS UP TO NOW 4.17.
GO AHEAD, JOE.
TAKE A BOW, AND THINGS AREN'T
GETTING BETTER ANY TIME SOON.
>> TODAY I'M ANNOUNCING THE
UNITED STATES IS TARGETING THE
MAIN ARTERY OF RUSSIA'S ECONOMY.
WE'RE BANNING ALL IMPORTS OF
RUSSIAN OIL AND GAS AND ENERGY.
THIS IS A STEP THAT WE'RE TAKING
TO INFLICT FURTHER PAIN ON
PUTIN.
BUT THERE WILL BE COST AS WELL
HERE IN THE UNITED STATES.
I SAID I WOULD LEVEL WITH THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE FROM THE
BEGINNING AND WHEN I FIRST SPOKE
TO THINK SAID DEFENDING FREEDOM
IS GOING TO COST, IT'S GOING TO
COST US AS WELL.
>> Jesse: YOU ARE DAMN RIGHT
IT'S GOING TO COST US.
IF YOU ONLY BAN RUSSIAN OIL AND
DON'T PUMP AMERICAN.
BIDEN PROMISED THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE HE WOULDN'T RAISE TAXES
ON ANYONE MAKING UNDER 400 Gs,
BUT IF THE COST OF YOUR EVERY
DAY LIFE SURGES, THANKS TO
INFLATION AND THIS GAS PRICE
SPIKE, THAT'S A TAX HIKE ON
EVERYBODY.
ENERGY CONSULTANTS ARE ALREADY
INCREASED FUEL COSTS ARE GOING
TO COST THE AVERAGE AMERICAN
HOUSEHOLD $2,000 MORE FOR
GASOLINE THIS YEAR.
$2,000 MORE.
THIS ISN'T JUST AN ENERGY CRISIS
WE ARE UP AGAINST.
IT'S AN ECONOMIC CRISIS, TOO.
BANNING RUSSIAN OIL AND NOT
REPLACING IT WITH A FUEL FROM
ANOTHER SOURCE LIKE WHAT WE ARE
DOING RIGHT HERE ISN'T A PLAN.
WELL, UNLESS YOUR EXPLAIN TO
DRIVE UP OIL PRICES.
IF THAT'S THE CASE, YOU ARE
DOING A GREAT JOB, JOE.
AND MAYBE THAT IS THE PLAN.
>> ACCELERATED TRANSITION TO
CLEAN ENERGY.
LOOSEN ENVIRONMENTAL REGULATIONS
PULLING BACK CLEAN ENERGY
INVESTMENT WON'T, LET ME REPEAT,
WILL NOT LOWER ENERGY PRICES FOR
FAMILIES.
BUT TRANSFORMING OUR ECONOMY TO
RUN ON ELECTRIC VEHICLES POWERED
BY CLEAN ENERGY, WITH TAX
CREDITS TO HELP AMERICAN
FAMILIES WINTERIZE THEIR HOMES
AND USE LESS ENERGY THAT WILL.
JET J.
>> Jesse: BIDEN CAN'T LET GOOD
CRISIS TO GO WASTE.
HE USED A PULPIT TO PUSH LITTLE
PET PROJECTS LIKE ELECTRIC
VEHICLES THAT YOU JUST HEARD HIM
TALKING ABOUT.
I MEAN, THAT'S LESS THAN 1% OF
CARS ON THE ROAD ARE ELECTRIC.
SUDDENLY, WE'RE SUPPOSED TO FILL
UP THE OTHER 99% OF AMERICA'S
ROADWAYS WITH EVs?
THAT'S BIDEN'S SHORT-TERM
SOLUTION?
ELECTRIC CARS ARE PRICY.
AND THEIR COST IS ONLY GOING TO
SURGE AS SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUES ARE
GOING TO MAKE THE PRICE OF THOSE
BATTERIES RISE.
SO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE STILL
REELING FROM A PANDEMIC
RECESSION AND FIGHTING HISTORIC
INFLATION, WE'RE SUPPOSED TO GO
OUT AND FORK OVER HARD EARNED
DOLLARS FOR A NEW ELECTRIC CAR.
AND THEN INSTALL LITTLE CHARGING
STATION IN THE GARAGE IF YOU
HAVE A GARAGE?
IS BIDEN NUTS?
WE HERE AT PRIME TIME WANTED TO
KNOW WHAT THE PEOPLE THOUGHT OF
THESE ENERGY POLICIES.
SO WE DID WHAT WE DO AND WE HIT
THE STREET.
♪
>> WHY AREN'T YOU DRIVING AN
ELECTRIC CAR?
JOE BIDEN SAYS THAT'S THE WAY TO
GO.
>> I DON'T HAVE $100,000.
>> IF I COULD AFFORD ONE I
WOULD.
>> I CAN'T AFFORD ONE.
>> TAKES A HALF HOUR TO FILL UP
ELECTRIC CAR.
>> I DON'T THINK TECH NO FOR
FULL LICK TRICK IS RIGHT THERE.
>> I DON'T CARE FOR ELECTRIC
CARS.
>> DO YOU PLAN ON BUYING AN
ELECTRIC CAR?
>> NO TIME SOON.
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
>> NOT RIGHT NOW.
>> NO.
>> MORE LIKE ELECTRIC PORTS
CHARGE CARD.
>> I WON'T BE ABLE TO AFFORD
ELECTRIC CARD I WILL BE OUT OF
MONEY BUYING GAS.
>> JOE BIDEN SAYS YOU ARE
POLLUTING IF YOU DON'T DRIVE AN
ELECTRIC CAR.
WHAT DO YOU HAVE TO SAY?
>> HOW AM I GOING TO WORK.
>> YOU NEED TO KEEP IN MIND HE
HAS BEEN RICH FOREVER.
A LOT OF PEOPLE CAN'T OH I'M
GOING TO SWITCH TO A TESLA.
>> HE BETTER FOCUS THE GAS PRICE
NOT ABOUT THE POLLUTION.
>> IF HE IS GOING TO SUPPORT US
AND BASICALLY GIVE US SOME
ELECTRIC CARS, I DON'T SEE WHY
NOT.
HE AIN'T GIVING NOBODY A CAR.
>> PRETTY ACCEPTED THAT WE ALL
POLLUTE.
IT'S PART OF OUR LIVES.
>> EVERYBODY ELSE IS POLLUTING.
>> YOU ARE POLLUTING IF YOU DO A
LOT OF THINGS.
I DON'T CARE WHAT BIDEN SAYS TO
BE HONEST.
JOE BIDEN DOESN'T KNOW WHAT HE
IS DOING AND WHAT IS HE DOING IN
THIS COUNTRY.
>> F. JOE BIDEN.
>> NOT ONLY ARE GAS PRICES ON
THE RISE, THEY ARE NOW THE MOST
EXPENSIVE THEY HAVE EVER BEEN IN
U.S. HISTORY.
HOW IS IT AFFECTING YOU.
>> YOU ARE KIDDING ME.
THAT NUMBER DEPRESSES ME, DUDE.
>> SHOPPING.
>> I TAKE THE.
>> I CHARGE PEOPLE TO GET IN MY
CAR.
>> I DON'T DRIVE MORE THAN
50 MILES THROUGH THE WEEK.
>> WE'RE MAKING LESS MONEY.
>> I MAKE LESS MONEY.
>> A LOT OF BILLS AND FOOD AND
GAS, EVERYTHING IS GOING UP.
>> I'M NOT ABLE TO AFFORD TO GET
GAS SOMETIMES.
I HAVE TO LEAVE MY CAR HOME
PARKED.
>> SOME DAYS I GO $50, $60.
YOU THINK THAT'S ENOUGH TO MAKE
A LIVING?
NO.
>> YOU ARE ON "JESSE WATTERS
PRIMETIME," IF PRESIDENT JOE
BIDEN IS FLIPPING THE CHANNELS
TONIGHT, WHAT DO YOU WANT TO
TELL HIM?
>> YOU KNOW, HELP US OUT, MAN.
>> WHAT'S WRONG WITH YOU, MAN?
>> GIVE ME AN ELECTRIC CAR, MAN.
>> DO A BETTER JOB.
>> PLEASE GET IT TOGETHER.
>> MORE STIMULUS MONEY, PLEASE.
>> WAKE UP.
>> HE BETTER COME RETIREMENT.
>> RETIRE.
>> WE WANT TRUMP BACK.
>> THE PEOPLE KNOW WHO TO BLAME
EVEN THOUGH BIDEN WON'T ACCEPT
IT.
JOE, THIS IS ALL PUTIN'S FAULT.
>> GOING TO GO UP.
CAN'T DO MUCH RIGHT NOW.
RUSSIA IS RESPONSIBLE.
>> Jesse: JUST MOTHER BIDEN FLIP
FLOP.
HE SPENT THE ENTIRE LAST WEEK
TELLING US IS HE DOING
EVERYTHING HE CAN TO LOWER GAS
PRICES.
BUT NOW SUDDENLY THERE IS
NOTHING HE CAN DO.
PUTIN PLAYED A PART FOR SURE BUT
GAS PRICES WERE AT 2.77 THIS
TIME LAST YEAR.
LONG BEFORE RUSSIA STARTED THIS
WAR.
SO, SORRY, JOE, THIS ONE IS ON
YOU, TOO.
ON YOUR FIRST DAY IN OFFICE YOU
KILLED THE PIPELINE AND PAUSED
DRILLING ON FEDERAL LAND.
YOU DIDN'T THINK THAT WOULD HAVE
SOME EFFECT ON GAS PRICES?
INSTEAD BIDEN CONTINUES TO LIE
TO OUR FACE ABOUT HIS ENERGY
POLICY.
LISTEN.
>> IT'S SIMPLY NOT TRUE THAT MY
ADMINISTRATION OR POLICIES ARE
HOLDING BACK DOMESTIC ENERGY
PRODUCTION.
THAT IS SIMPLY NOT TRUE.
>> Jesse: HERE'S WHAT IS TRUE, A
JUDGE JUST REVOKED THE BIGGEST
FEDERAL OFFSHORE LEASE IN U.S.
HISTORY AND BIDEN WON'T APPEAL
THE RULING.
HE WON'T APPEAL IT.
SO HE JUST KILLED THE BIGGEST
FEDERAL ENERGY LEASE OF ALL
TIME.
JOE BIDEN.
WILL GULF OF MEXICO.
ANOTHER RECORD YOU BROKE, JOE.
WAY TO GO.
YOU SEE, BIDEN CARES MORE ABOUT
HIS FAR LEFT BASE THAN HE CARES
ABOUT DOING WHAT'S BEST FOR THE
COUNTRY.
HE IS LOOKING TO HELP AOC
INSTEAD OF YOU.
IT'S VERY ALARMING THAT MANY OF
THE PEOPLE PUSHING TO INCREASE
AND SKYROCKET EITHER IMPORT OR
PRODUCTION, DOMESTIC PRODUCTION
IN THE SHORT-TERM ARE NOT
TALKING ABOUT WHAT WE REALLY
NEED TO BE DOING IN TERMS OF
RAPID INVESTMENT SOLAR AND WIND.
>> Jesse: SOLAR AND WIND.
CITIZEN STEAD OF LISTENING TO
PLEASE PEOPLE BIDEN NEEDS TO
COME UP WITH A PLAN TO LOWER
ENERGY COSTS NOW NOT BECOME THE
PUNCH LINE OF LATE NIGHT JOKES.
>> SINCE THE INVASION, OIL
PRICES HAVE SKYROCKETED.
TODAY, THE AVERAGE GAFFES PRICE
IN AMERICA HIT AN ALL-TIME
RECORD HIGH OF OVER $4 PER
GALLON.
OKAY.
CLEAN CONSCIENCE IS WORTH A BUCK
OR TWO.
I'M WILLING TO PAY $4 A GALLON.
HELL, I WILL PAY $15 A GALLON
BECAUSE I DRIVE A TESLA.
>> Jesse: OF COURSE YOU DO.
IT'S NOT JUST THE LEFT.
ALL OF AMERICA'S ENEMIES ARE
LAUGHING AT US AS WE TRY TO TURN
FOR ENERGY NEEDS.
BIDEN IS GOING HAT IN HAND
BEGGING KINGS AND DICTATORS AND
SAUDI ARABIA AND VENEZUELA AND
POSSIBLY EVEN THE MULLAHS IN
TRIUNE PUMP MORE OIL.
HE WANTS TO PAY BLOOD MONEY TO
THESE COUNTRIES FOR THEIR FUEL
WHILE THEY TURN AROUND AND USE
THE CASH TO CONTINUE TO
TERRORIST US AND THEIR OWN
PEOPLE.
WELL, IF THEY TAKE HIS CALL.
THERE IS A NEW REPORT IN THE
"WALL STREET JOURNAL" TONIGHT
CLAIMING BIDEN GOT CERTIFIED BY
THE SAUDIS.
JOE BIDEN CALLED AND THE CROWNED
PRINCE REFUSED TO PICK UP THE
PHONE.
DIDN'T TAKE THE CALL FROM THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
SO MUCH FOR BEING THE MOST
POWERFUL MAN IN THE WORLD.
AND FOR THE WHOLE CLIMATE CHANGE
CROWD, THE OIL THAT WE MAKE HERE
IN THE U.S. IS PRODUCED CLEANER
THAN ANY PLACE ON EARTH.
SO BIDEN'S PLAN IS TO BUY
DIRTIER OIL WHILE MAKING OUR
ENEMIES RICH.
BOY, IS THAT STUPID?
BUT HERE'S A NOVEL IDEA,
MR. PRESIDENT.
HOW ABOUT WE USE MORE OF OUR OWN
OIL HERE RATHER THAN ASK BAD
GUYS TO THROW US A BONE.
AND IF YOU ARE OPEN TO
SUGGESTIONS, WE HAVE A FEW.
FOR STARTERS, HOW ABOUT WE
REPEAL THE GAS TAX, EVEN MEMBERS
OF YOUR OWN PARTY ARE PUSHING
IT.
>> WE NEED TO SUSPEND THE GAS
TAX 18.4 CENTS A GALLON.
IT WILL REDUCE THE INFLATIONARY
PRESSURES THAT ARE CAUSING
RISING GAS PRICES AT THE PUMP
AND AMERICANS SHOULD BE ANGRY.
>> Jesse: NEVER THOUGHT I WOULD
SAY THIS BUT LISTEN TO RICHARD
BLUMENTHAL.
AND DON'T STOP THERE, HOW ABOUT
YOU CUT THE ETHANOL BLENDING
MANDATE.
THAT ACTUALLY CAUSES MORE
POLLUTION THEY JUST DISCOVERED.
AND WHILE WE'RE AT IT, LET'S
OPEN ALASKA FOR BUSINESS.
ALASKA HAS BILLIONS OF BARRELS
OF OIL READY TO BE PULLED OUT OF
THE GROUND.
TIME TO RESTORE THE SUSPENDED
LEASES ON THE ARTIC NATIONAL
WILDLIFE REFUGE.
THERE IS 600,000 SQUARE MILES OF
ALASKA WITH MOST OF IT FERTILE
DRILLING LAND.
LOOK AT THAT THIS IS HOW WE
RESTORE AMERICAN ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE.
WE BECOME SELF-SUFFICIENT ON OIL
AND GAS AND THEN WE CAN SELL IT
TO OUR ALLIES WHO NEED IT IN
EUROPE.
WHY DO WE KEEP POURING MONEY
INTO THE POCKETS OF OUR ENEMIES?
LET'S PROTE